et j'ai une note pour moi ah non mais tu
étais bien meilleur d'ailleurs quand tu
étais pas là on va tout était mis
[Applaudissements]
franchement ça va coûter très bon chez
moi ça va les séances sinon les sciences
du V ça ça prend bien alors je ne veux
pas d'user mais arrêtez des conneries
frère
on dirait que tu as on dirait on dirait
pourquoi le soleil comme les autres mais
euh
[Applaudissements]
Canada sur le visage on va mettre des
lignes de terrain de tennis
qui rend rouge comme ça
alors là c'est pas normal
on va rigoler il a fait des douches
encore
mais oui
je rappelle que l'alcool et dangereux
pour la santé moi j'ai adoré tous les
thés franchement
[Applaudissements]
non mais il était content il avait ça va
il était content de faire défoncer
je vais raconter Benjamin Castaldi
Benjamin Castaldi tous les jours il a
passé cinq jours à la maison toujours
non moi je vois pas une boule d'alcool
apparemment 11h
11h du matin non à part à 14h30 je crois
que l'apéro à 15h15 j'ai quand même
avant de partir je prends quand même un
petit truc à 17h quand je me lève de
l'assiette sinon je bois pas à 18h aussi
bah attends c'est bon ça va être la fin
de la journée à 20h bah attends avant de
manger un petit apéro quand même oh 22h
un petit digestif et en fait je
t'explique à 15h il est pour rien
dans la maison
[Applaudissements]
est dangereux pour la santé je n'ai pas
besoin de le dire les gens le vois non
mais c'est pareil
il faut se regarder d'abord une
télévision bien réglée pour voir que
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas fou non
mais c'est vrai pour voir que ce n'est
pas fou fou fou
quand il t'appelle Guillaume Genton
toutes les vacances alors que tu as ma
tête oui il y a un problème il a été sur
le bateau Guillaume Genton frère et il a
fait n'importe quoi
il a loué un bateau pour la journée
voilà il a loué un bateau pour la
journée mon Guigui comportement
inacceptable il a eu un comportement
inacceptable à tes côtés à faire la meuf
de Guillaume j'entends il a commencé à
vouloir lui mettre de la crème sur le
corps
et en fait
s'il vous plaît je suis son producteur
c'est mon ami hein
Virgin Radio merci attention
inacceptable mon bébé dès que j'avais le
dos tourné il lui proposait une merguez
[Musique]
c'est vrai il était il était sur le
bateau de Guillaume qu'il avait loué il
était rébou mon frère ça ne bougeait pas
nous a dit qu'il y avait un fond de
force 7 non mais arrêtez un karaoké et
mettre et passer de la crème ils ont
fait un carreau avec la main sur les
fesses non mais dis-moi alors karaoké
sur le bateau
[Musique]
la meuf de
sport
[Musique]
avec ma femme bien de bordel je vais
ranger toute la soirée merci beaucoup
merci on va rentrer ce soir
c'est pas grave
voilà Aurore quand il rentre à la maison
prépare lui comme d'habitude un petit
digestif je rappelle que la vue d'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé voilà mais
Benjamin voilà je rappelle que Benjamin
de bois pas une goutte d'eau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est le seul gars
il me dit qu'il fait du sport toute
l'année je l'ai jamais vu courir pendant
les vacances ni même aller chercher un
truc c'est un truc où est-ce que Raymond
tu l'as vu pourri on fait un truc
Guillaume est-ce que tu l'as vu je l'ai
vu boire par contre
[Applaudissements]
il a pas besoin de nager avec ses seins
il flotte
[Applaudissements]
il y avait Guillaume il y avait Raymond
il y avait Daniel on a pas voulu la voir
il y avait Olivier
il y avait une petite équipe quoi on
était bien bah oui
il a loué un bateau c'était tous à la
maison